[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Planet Costa
College today I'll be taking a look at
one of the weirdest coasters in the game
the free swing coaster pioneer or as
it's more known in real life the free
fly coaster made by S&S there's only one
of these in the world but it's a small
family coaster which doesn't rely so
much on speed and g-forces to be
exciting but really on these very
strange cars that it has that make it
seem as though you're flying around this
albatross and I know that sounds very
weird so let's take a look at this thing
in game and show you how to build one
now as per usual when we built the
station I want to raise it up a little
bit especially since I also want to go
down after this station and I'm gonna
actually change it to an exit and an
entry on separate sides because that's a
little bit more realistic and I will
keep the angle snap on actually for
making this curve go do about 45 degrees
built that I remove it again so that I
can now turn off angle snap and keep it
at the same perfect angle snapped curve
angle well at the same time going down a
little bit so that we can go into the
little now that's all good and we want
to start going into the lift to itself I
have a very small straight section where
it hooks onto the chain and at that
point I am not really sure how steep
these lift Hill should be exactly I
think somewhere between 25 and 30
degrees there are somewhat gentle lift
tables which I suspect has something to
do with the ways that these cars are set
up since they are very open and have
barely anything really holding you in
it's it's definitely safe nonetheless
but you don't to make these rights too
uncomfortable so in any case just
building a very very gentle lift Hill
something like that I do want to make
sure that I have my height markers on
here and go for about a height of 20
meters there's only one of these in real
life so there isn't too much reference
to go by but from what they're saying on
their website of what as an s is saying
on the website
from what the prototype is like it is
definitely a family coaster and
especially with the focus on that
sensation of flying instead of the
forces or the speed you don't make these
things too tall really keep them well
doable for the children and the parents
and everybody in the family basically so
somewhere between 20 to 25 meters should
be very realistic and I definitely think
you can go higher than that and maybe do
some very creative stuff with these
coasters as long as you don't make them
too intense I think they will still be
very realistic kind of fantasy ride
anyway something to keep in mind about
the chairlift is that we do want to go
down just a little bit with that chain
just to make sure that it's actually off
the chain as it goes down and there we
are now next we're going into the actual
track and I'll also be using this to
show of what this course is going to
look like so I'll already start a quick
test and also start building the first
curve over here and I'm gonna be very
careful with these curves and trying to
make it as smooth as I can very gradual
banking and very gradual curve and of
going straight again I think should work
we'll see how it's gonna work out one
thing that is really really important
about these things is to make it as
smooth as you can I'll smooth this out
before the car goes over it so that we
can quickly have a look at what it's
going to look like so basically no
matter what the orientation of the track
is whether it's going through an
inversion or whether it is completely
upside down the carriages that you're
sitting in should never invert
they do swing a little bit which you can
definitely notice and that'll make sure
that you are actually kind of swinging
to the sides in all of the curves which
is pretty neat but they don't actually
go upside down at least they don't in
the prototype I definitely think that
would make things way too out of hand
and way too extreme especially for this
being a family coaster but basically I
think it's it's pretty good to go with
this curve it's maybe a little bit slow
you know speed it up a little bit
naked a tiny bit steeper there we go you
can definitely make this first curve
very small this is all still inspired by
the only prototype that's out there but
I would really say you can do just about
anything you want with these things as
long as you make sure that it's not too
intense and remember that the appeal of
these things is not actually in the
track that they're riding or the layout
that they have but really in the types
of cars that these things have which is
so unique one thing which I will say
though is that smoothing is the most
important thing as you can sell that
just looked like a very very weird
movement as the Front's of the carriage
I was moving in a different direction
because of the sudden banking then the
back of it and that causes all kinds of
jerkiness so no matter whether you're
building very small or very large
version of these coasters I would say
that the smoothing is really what it
comes down to and what is the most
important thing to keep in mind because
if the track isn't smooth then every
little bump and every little sudden
transition in the banking is just going
to be intensified for the movements on
those carriages so that's the one thing
you want to keep in mind but that aside
a lot of these courses are just kind of
you lick sing around so I think that's
something we can definitely do over here
as well just head into another curve and
see where it's gonna take us I have no
idea the one in real life just kind of
helixes around itself which is of course
a very space efficient way to get around
building these things but I don't want
to be too restrictive and say that
that's the only thing you can do that's
just how these are realistically made so
I think some curve like this would be
pretty fun now I think it's also time
that we get into what these things do
which makes them a little bit more
interesting than just the boring track
so what they will do in real life
or what the existing one does in real
life is have these curves where during
the curve it actually goes upside down
and I think that's an interesting thing
to try so basically we want to have a
curve
and just kind of gradually start moving
that track upside down don't worry too
much about it not being smooth we'll
make sure to smooth that out quite a bit
once we've actually finished the curve
there we go can actually reduce the
banking and some of those turns a little
bit yeah that that should just about do
all right now that curve is more or less
done actually do want to turn on angle
snap here to make sure that we're
getting to 180 degrees and now it's
pretty much time to grab that entire
curve I normally would actually speak
out against smoothing out like this but
for a coaster like this where the
smoothness of the banking is really the
most important factor in making it a
comfortable coaster to ride I think a
very easy shortcut is to just select
everything at the same time and hit that
smooth button many times until it's as
smooth as you can get it there we go
so here it's going also with the
swinging of the cars I would say it can
definitely be fun to keep in mind the
way that the track is banking it's kind
of influenced the way that their cars or
the carriages are swinging so for
instance this quick curve over here make
sure that they're swinging into this
direction and then as soon as the
swinging back toward the center follow
it up with another curve going into the
other direction so they can swing in
that direction instead just kind of make
use of that little swinging action
that's going on now at this point I
think we're almost good to go with the
brake run but with how launched this
coast is probably gonna get I think we
could also just have one more curve and
at that point go into a small mid-course
brake run these block brakes are very
important if we want to run multiple
trains on this coaster in a realistic
way so I think it's about time to head
back into a horizontal section again and
add one more helix into this ride so
what I would actually like to do is
since we kind of came from that
direction in terms of the banking I'm
gonna turn back into that direction
again and see what we can do here I
think a long winding curve over here
underneath the section of track where
you've come before it's actually quite
fitting and we'll have this go back up
into one it's going to be the mid-course
break run it's kind of sitting besides
the lift hill here and not too sure
about the exact speed which I'm supposed
to be getting here so I'll just have to
test that for a second but I think this
should more or less do it looks like an
alright speed coming through that curve
quite smoothly and into the block brakes
all right I'll take it
now this block break pretty much marks
the middle point for the coaster and off
to this block break in the real life
version it just does a couple of very
wide turns very low to the ground and
after that goes back into the station
but I do want to insert a little bit
more creativity in this because I would
love if this was actually a more used
coaster time because you barely see
these things at all being made at planet
coaster or real life either but
something which could be a lot of fun
since there's only one of these in real
life is that there's a lot of space to
mess around with there's a lot of stuff
which hasn't been tried in real life
with this kind of coaster which you can
come up with in planets coaster I'll
show you an example in a little bit but
first I want to get into a quick curve
and just get a little bit of speed again
and get a bit close to the ground and
make sure that the layout is not going
to end up being too wide and especially
as we're coming to the ground actually I
want to make sure that this curve is not
too steep and that it's not too small
that we're not putting too many forces
on people are mostly just swinging those
carriages
so let's smooth out the entire thing
just hit the smooth button quite a few
times I think something like that looks
quite good I do want to give extra care
to the transitions though since they're
very important to get those things
smooth let's check it out
Alex very nice now one thing which the
real-life version doesn't have which I
think could be very interesting for
these kinds of courses is an inline
twist which is basically a 360 roll and
especially because it has those
interesting carriages I think this could
be a very cool elements add to these
kinds of coasters I'll show in a second
what I think makes them so interesting
so basically we just want to have a
bunch of track sections which all
rotates to about 90 degrees so here's
the first one
here's the second one let's get that 180
there we go and then we get into the
last one now the actual last one oh
looks like I was a little bit too close
to ground there hopefully I can still
make it
oh nope alright it's going to decide a
little bit more soft that issue so I'm
pretty happy with that and this is
basically a very long winded inline
twist the reason why I do think you want
to make it long minded is that the
banking on these coasters is always very
long line it since it has such a huge
impact on the carriages and on the way
that you're sitting in this coaster that
you want to make sure that the banking
is or as smooth as and and as continuous
as you can and as you can tell it takes
quite a bit of smoothing to make sure
that a role of a inline twist like this
is actually as smooth as you can and it
gets messed up when you select the
entire thing at once so really this just
takes a lot of trial and error and using
a lot of smoothy smooth to make sure
that it's as smooth as possible but if
you do get it right you get that a very
interesting effect where the carriages
revolve around the middle of the track
which i think is very cool there we go
with a little bit more smoothing it
should now be a nice smooth transition
and I think after that we can already
head back into the station because I do
want to end this thing with another blog
break section making sure that we can
fit another train on there but also to
make sure that we can actually break
down the coaster a little bit more or
break the speed a little bit before we
head into the station so I'm gonna start
at the end
as I usually like to do make sure we
have a bit of an incline going here and
at the block breaks and the regular
breaks to make sure that the coaster
slows down all right now with that all
taken care of
let's get into the very last curve now I
do have quite a bit of speed left over
here and I'm gonna be very careful and
very smooth so I'll just move out a
little bit here actually make that curve
still go down so that the very final
curve can go up a little bit and all I'm
really making sure over here is that my
final curve is as smooth as I can get it
and it's very long winding curve since
we still have quite a bit of speed left
let's pick that a little bit less steep
and see how we can head back into the
brake run at the end there and
especially toward the end of the curve
where it's a little bit higher up we
should definitely be losing some speed
so I can make that curve a little
tighter here and then toward the end
basically finish off the right like
that's doesn't really matter that it
looks absolutely terrible because the
smoothing tool will take care of most of
that it will also take care of some of
the banking here so I want to make sure
that I actually do keep the banking
round here and then finally that
transition is a very important area so
I'll smooth this out and extra bits and
I think we should now be more or less
good to go let's see it coming there we
go and into the last curve to swing a
little bit better and with a nice bead
into the brakes all right that was
basically the planet coaster College
video about the free fly coaster also
known as the free swing in planets
coaster I know this has been a bit of a
weird video for this series I was
definitely doubting whether I should do
it but I kind of promised myself and the
viewers I guess in a way that I would do
all the courses in the game and explain
how they all work and this was on the
list and it fits together with the S&S
and arrow courses that i've done in the
past couple of episodes so I figured I
would just give it a try and make a
short episode about it I think the most
important
thing that I do wanna say about these
coasters especially because it's just a
prototype in real life and I'm not even
sure if any more are gonna be built at
all my most important message is just
that this is a family coaster but you
can mess with it as much as you want I
think there are some very creative ideas
that you could come up with with this
type of ride with having cars like this
which no other coaster has actually for
some trivia I believe the reason why as
an S stated that these things are not
being built anymore is simply because no
company wants them no park is really
asking for them since the existing one
doesn't really have too great of a
throughput in terms of the capacity that
has per hour since the availability of
these rides are just eight riders per
train I think they put out a new
prototype which hasn't been sold
anywhere which has 16 riders per train
not too sure about that
but anyway that one of the issues with
these things is just that they're not
that efficient and it's it's a very
weird experimental kind of ride it's not
very safe choice to go for with the park
that's why I think these things are
barely being built anywhere but I
personally think it's a really
interesting coaster it's definitely very
unique and at key it can still provide a
very interesting experience I think for
being a family coaster which ultimately
doesn't really hits any high speeds it
doesn't really get any high g-forces but
it just has a very interesting premise
and concept anyway that was about enough
coaster ranting for me today I hope to
be back with you for the next much more
serious planet coaster college with the
multi-dimensional or four-dimensional
coaster from S&S next week so stay tuned
for that
and thank you all for watching